et on poursuit d'ailleurs avec cette
question de michel un clément bonne elle
a été posée sur nos réseaux sociaux et
il se demande pourquoi ne fait-on pas
marcher encore plus la planche à billets
pour relancer la croissance européenne
l'inflation est elle réellement la seule
raison c'est une question très concrète
en tant que jeune michel il ne comprend
pas faire marcher la planche à billets
ne coûte rien à l'europe non alors
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez la
banque centrale doit-elle injecter plus
d'argent dans l'économie clément bonne à
la planche à billets comme l'argent en
général c'est pas totalement magique qui
nous plaît donc on ne peut pas imaginer
que il n'ya aucune limite à ce fait de
créer de la monnaie mais néanmoins c'est
michel à raison l'importance de l'action
de la banque centrale dans cette crise
est absolument essentiel est là pour
reprendre l'expression traditionnelle
fait marcher beaucoup la planche à
billets on nous compare souvent aux
états unis et souvent on a l'impression
que les américains font beaucoup plus
fort beaucoup plus vite que nous sur le
plan monétaire ce n'est pas exact la
banque centrale européenne dès le mois
de mars 2020 a racheté beaucoup de
titres sur les marchés concrètement a
injecté beaucoup d'argent et ça a
soutenu l'économie très concrètement
parce que ça paraît toujours un peu
abstrait ça a soutenu les entreprises ça
a permis des prêts à très bas coût à
coût nul et cette action de planche à
billets ou daniel d'action monétaire de
la banque centrale
elle est extrêmement puissante et
christine lagarde sa présidente la
banque centrale européenne l'ont dit ça
continuera le temps nécessaire à
soutenir la crise et à côté de ça on a
aussi utilisé notre budget c'est aussi
de l'argent qu'on met ensemble pour
financer notamment la relance c'est le
plan de relance européen de 750
milliards d'euros qu'on finance aussi
par de l'emprunt
mais après il faut être clair d'être se
rembourse progressivement et d'ailleurs
ça n'est pas très grave comme le disait
michel parce que nous avons aujourd'hui
une situation d'emprunt qui est
favorable mais il faut pas croire que
les dettes s'efface que la planche à
billets fonctionne sans aucune limite
il faut aussi qu'on soit sérieux dans la
gestion de cet argent et sans doute
après la crise pas trop vite parce que
parfois les européens sont allés trop
vite pour
revenir à la situation d'avant crise
nous devrons quand même adapter nos
règles budgétaires notre politique
monétaire mais cela viendra un peu plus
tard en tout cas faut être clair
l'action européenne budgétaire et
monétaire
tout l'argent qui a été injecté dans
cette crise c'est aussi un modèle
européen de solidarité de protection
qu'on a activé franchement est-ce que
partout dans le monde pendant cette
crise alors il faut l'avoir en tête
aussi
raphaël glucksmann nous avons reçu pour
cette fête de l'europe beaucoup de
commentaires négatifs ayant trait à la
solidarité la générosité européenne
malgré ce grand plan de relance que vous
mentionnez tous de 750 milliards d'euros
dominique vous demande quelle europe
l'europe des peuples ou l'europe des
marchés moi je voudrais dire d'abord
avant de répondre à dominique que à
michel et bien qu'il a raison et si
c'est vrai que la solidarité a
fonctionné et que finalement les états
et l'union européenne ont été là pour
rêver éviter que tout s'effondre pendant
cette crise les plans de relance sont
trop faibles
et quand on les compare aux plans de
relance américain on comprend qu'il y a
finalement une cuisine là limité au
niveau européen et que j'espère que ça
n'annonce pas
monsieur bonne ensuite un tour de vis
parce que en réalité on est en train de
clore un cycle là et il faut qu'on
arrive à le comprendre
on clôt le cycle de l'orthodoxie
budgétaire et on clôt aussi le cycle du
libre-échange généralités et de la
concurrence libre et non faussée érigé
en dogme et c'était ça l'europe des
marchés et en fait il y à il ya besoin
là d'un retour du politique et de la
cité l'écologie le demande la situation
sociale le demande le fait aussi que
nous cessions progressivement d'être un
continent de producteurs l'exigent
il ya la nécessité justement de passer
pourrait vendre à dominique à une europe
politique et non plus une europe qui se
contente d'être un marché et qui
considèrent des règles qui sont somme
toute des règles aléatoire qui ne sont
fondés en rien sur du sacré ou sur la
volonté d'un dieu et bien qu'ils
considèrent ces règles comme une
religion il faut sortir de cela pendant
la crise
on a su sortir de cela et il faut que ça
soit définitif il ya une politique qui a
été menée il faut le dire aussi parce
que je suis sûr que monsieur ghosn est
d'accord avec moi qui a été menée suite
à la crise financière d'il ya dix ans
qui a été catastrophique qui a conduit
les grecs à vendre le port du pirée au
chinois les les portugais à vendre leurs
banques
tout cela pour et bien éviter le déficit
budgétaire
et finalement on a eu une europe qui est
sorti exemple de la crise financière il
ne faut absolument pas reproduire la
même erreur
il faut désormais affirmer une puissance
politique européenne ça passe par des
plans de relance plus ambitieux et par
et bien une rupture avec les logiques
qui ont conduit l'europe d'en revenir
sur 30 ans et
[Musique]